من جهته وصف الرئيس الاوكرانيه الوضع في
الجبهه الشرقيه بانه صعب جدا ومؤلم جدا
كما انا عن دعم مالي للجيش بقيمه 13 مليار
دولار
كنت اليوم على اتصال مع قادتنا المعلومات
الاستخباريه تصرف الوضع في الشرق بانه صعب
جدا ومؤلم جدا يجب علينا تدمير القوه
العسكريه للعدو وسوف ندمرها الحكومه وافقت
واقترحت على البرلمان الاوكراني ان يوافق
على زياده ميزانيه الدفاع ستوجه جميع
الاموال الى دعم الجيش خصوصا في قطاع
الدفاع والمعدات الدفاعيه بما في ذلك
الطائرات بدون طيار سنفعل كل ما هو ممكن
ومستحيل لتقويه جنودنا
نتابع التفاصيل وتطورات مع مراسلين من
كراماتورز كحسان مسعود ومن موسكو رانيا
اهلا بكما من جديد حسان القصف الروسي على
تلك المباني حيث تقف فكره ما اخر حصيله له
وما الذي خلفه ايضا على مستوى تدمير الذي
طال هذه البنايات
نعم قبل دقائق اكد لنا جهاز الطوارئ
بارتفاع عدد الضحايا في هذا الهجوم
الصاروخي الذي استهدف المباني السكنيه وسط
مدينه كراماتورسك الى قتيل واربعه
جرحه حتى هذه اللحظه وفق المعطيات الاوليه
وما زالت فرق الانقاذ تعمل في المكان
نشاهد اثار القصف الذي تعرض له هذا المبنى
وعدد ايضا من المباني المحيطه في مجمع
سكني وسط المدينه نحن بالقرب من الساحه
الرئيسيه لمدينه كراماتورسك وهذه المنطقه
هي التي تعرضت لهذا القصف الصاروخي الذي
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم الافصاح بشكل واضح
عن نوع الصاروخ الذي استهدف المكان ولكن
على ما يظهر فان هذه الصواريخ ادت الى
اضرار كبيره هذا القصف الذي نشاهده ياتي
في الاطار عدد من الضربات الصاروخيه التي
استهدفت المدن المحيطه بمدينه اكراماتورز
او بمدينه باخمت
في الحقيقه وهذا ياتي ايضا في اطار
محاولات قصف المباني والمنشات
الحيويه التي
تؤدي في طريقها الى منطقه بخموت في ظل
مواصله القتال ومواصله المعارك في منطقه
باخموت خلال الايام الماضيه تعرضت منطقه
لعده ضربات صاروخيه اصابت منشاه حيويه
بالاضافه الى قصف طالب منطقه كستنت ايفكا
هذه المدينه ايضا التي تقع غرب منطقه
كراماتورس كهذه الضربات تاتي في ظل ايضا
استمرار تحليق الطيران الحربي الروسي فوق
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
جنوب غرب باخموت وهذا ايضا بدا يظهر
وبدانا نلاحظه
متصاعد خلال الايام الماضيه تحليق الطيران
الروسي فوق المناطق التي تسيطر عليها وشنه
لغارات جويه خلال النهار على المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه لا سيما في
المنطقه الغربيه كل ذلك يشير الى ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول ان تتقدم باتجاه
المنطقه الغربيه بهدف احكام السيطره على
منطقه بخموت من الجهه الاخيره التي ما
زالت بيد القوات الاوكرانيه ولم تستطع
القوات الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه احكام
السيطره عليها هذا ياتي ايضا في ظل تاكيد
القوات الاوكرانيه على
مواصلتها للدفاع على المنطقه على المنطقه
الغربيه تحديدا من الجهتين الجنوبيه
والشماليه بالاضافه الى محاولات القوات
الاوكرانيه بشكل متواصل صد الهجمات التي
تشنها القوات الروسيه ومقاتل فاجنر على
من عدد من الاتجاهات اليوم هيئه الاركان
العليا تحدثت عن هجوم حاولت القوات
الروسيه التقدم من الجهه الشماليه ومن
الجهه الجنوبيه للمنطقه الغربيه تحدثت عن
صد القوات الاوكرانيه لهجوم عند منطقه
تشاسيفيار هذه المدينه التي تعتبر خزان
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه الفتره تؤدي
بطريقها هي اقرب منطقه كبيره لمنطقه
باخموت عبر هذا الطريق الفرعي منها يتم
امداد القوات
الاوكرانيه المتمركزه في منطقه وما زال
هذا الامداد وهذه
المساعدات والدعم العسكري مستمر طيله
الوقت عبر هذه الطرقات يبدو ان القوات
الروسيه حاولت التقدم باتجاه هذه المنطقه
والقوات الاوكرانيه تصدت لها وفق ما اكدت
هيئه الاركان يضاف الى ذلك حديث هيئه
الارجان عن صد القوات الاوكرانيه لهجوم
عند منطقه ايفاني هذه المنطقه تقع وسط
الطريق الرئيسيه
التي تؤدي ما بين منطقه كوستانتيف كاب
وايضا منطقه كراماتورسك ومنطقه بخموت في
المنطقه الغربيه
ننظر الى موسكو والمواقف جديده المواقف
السياسيه ايضا والانباء حول التطورات
العسكريه رانيا
الاهم حتى هذه اللحظه عبد الصمد هو ما تم
الاعلان عنه من قبل وكالات اعلام رسميه
تتحدث عن ان القوات فاجنر تمت السيطره على
مصنع بسطوك
ماش وهذا المصنع هو يعني من الناحيه
المعنويه مصنع في غايه الاهميه كون هذا
المصنع كان
الرئيسكي في شهر ديسمبر الماضي اي قبل نحو
ثلاثه اشهر كان هناك يقدم الاوسمه لقواته
العامله في منطقه واليوم هذا المصنع بات
تحت السيطره قوات فاكتور في على الصعيد
الميداني تستمر المعارك في المدينه قوات
فاجنر بحسب المعطيات الصادره عن هذه
الشركه تشون حرب شوارع عنيفه في المناطق
الشماليه من المدينه فضلا عن ذلك ايضا تشن
عمليات هجميه في مصنع ارث
للمعادن هنا تحاول ضرب مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه وتحصيناتها في انفاق هذا
المصنع من جهه اخرى تستمر ايضا القوات
الروسيه بالتعاون ايضا مع قوات فاجنر
بالتقدم في مختلف المناطق في محور باخموت
الحديث يدور عن ضرب مواقع المواقع
الدفاعيه لقوات القوات الاوكرانيه في
منطقه
هنا ود الاشاره الى انه تم الاعلان عن ان
غالبيه المناطق في في هذه المنطقه او
غالبيه الاراضي في هذه المنطقه باتت تحت
السيطره القوات بالتزامن مع ذلك القوات
المسلحه الروسيه ايضا تتقدم في منطقه
زليزيانسك زليزيانسكايا وهناك حديث عن ان
هناك تقدم للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في
مختلف المحاور في هذه الجبهه وهناك
انذارات من قبل الخبراء والمواقع العسكريه
والم العسكريين تتحدث من مغبه مصير القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في مدينه فيما اذا لم
تنسحب وتترك هذه المدينه خلال الايام
القليله المقبله وهنا وادي التذكير
بتصريحات رئيس شركه فاغنر او مالك شركه
فاجنر الذي اشار الى ان على انه بالفعل
على الرغم من ان المعارك صعبه وتزداد
ضراوه مع وصول قواته الى مركز المدينه لكن
الامور حسب تعبيره تتجه نحو تحقيق النصر
من جهه اخرى لا بد من الاشاره على مختلف
الجبهات الاخرى الى ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وفقا لما صدرت صباح اليوم من
قبل السلطات المحليه في دنباص الموالي
لروسيا تتحدث عن ان القصف الاوكراني مستمر
في استهداف الاحياء السكنيه عبد الصمد على
سبيل المثال امس تم القضاء على مدنيين في
مقاطعه خلال القصف الاوكراني الذي طال
ثمانيه احياء سكنيه باك من 100 قذيفه
ناهيك عن ايضا عن اعلان السلطات المحليه
عن استمرار القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
باستخدام الاسلحه الامريكيه
صواريخ اوراق جيمات هاي الامريكيه وكانت
صباح اليوم كانت قد قصفت منطقه كراس
نيللوش في مقاطعه لوغاز بسته صواريخ من
طراز شكرا
مسعود وكان معنا من كرامات شكرا لكم